if I were to give one piece of advice
well we'll make it to number one is
patience true power means you're patient
enough to allow that power to come to
fruition so it means at the top of my
swing and if it's if it is the games and
you are doing the overhead swing fine
you got to do what's required for the
competition you have to wait for those
arms to reconnect for your to your ribs
before you hinge then you have to allow
yourself the time to hinge before you
hit the quick turnaround and now you got
to be patient keeping the arms against
the body as long as you can so you have
this full transfer of energy from the
hips and midsection to the arms in the
Bell and so what I see a lot of people
do is they rush that they hinge too
early on the way down they're trying to
come up too quick on the way up and
they're letting the arms disconnect
before they've fully expressed the power
from their hips so if they would it
display patience at those three stages
wait long enough for the arms to
reconnect on the way down give yourself
time to hinge and then keep the arms
against the ribs as long as possible as
you're producing power through the
ground you're gonna find a much more
powerful swing and better transfer of
energy
I'm joined by Brett Jones director of
education at strong first Brett welcome
to show excellent it's great to be with
you today and really looking forward to
speaking with you and your audience yeah
me too
we we haven't touched on strength that
much yet not in its not in its purity
we've we've circled around it a little
bit but we're talking all things strong
today right absolutely
there's strength has been it's been a
something I pursued for most of my adult
life in in various forms and I look
forward to the conversation on it yeah
it's gonna be good will have some
CrossFit as some power lifters tuning in
amongst people that just want to be able
if to shop in a bit shopping a little
bit heavier I guess as well so they
might benefit as well um absolutely
talking about strength how do you as
someone who spends his entire time
thinking about strength how do you
define strength so strength can be so if
we first go with this this idea of
physical strength that can be your
ability to produce tension your ability
to produce force against an outside
object or to manipulate your own body
against a given leverage or position so
it's the ability to produce tension to
produce force against an object and
manipulate an object or your own body
like I said so that that's kind of the
the 30,000 foot view when you if you get
into the mechanics of it there's
obviously a lot more going on when you
go beyond physical strength and that's
you know within strong first one of our
we we have actually have like a code of
conduct where students of strength were
quiet professionals and we believe the
strength has a greater purpose and the
mission of strong first is to pursue
promote and practice strength because we
believe strength has a greater purpose
and that greater purpose obviously
transcends physical strength into many
other areas my grandmother is one of the
strongest people that I know of on the
planet and she's never lifted a weight
in her
and so we're not just referring to this
concept of physical strength we do
believe that building physical strength
can provide a window into greater
strength in one's life in many areas not
just the physical I understand so yeah
you've touched on one of the the two
taglines I suppose or one of the the two
major elements that strong forces would
use strength has a greater purpose and
strength is the master quality that
right yes so if you look at met viev
said that strength is a foundation of
physical development to strength for the
for all qualities of physical
development so I I remember being in a
talk with Eric Cressey years ago and you
know Eric gave a great analogy people
have tried to give me credit for it so
every time I get an opportunity I give
him credit for it because it's where I
heard it but basically he said you know
strength is the glass every other
quality you want to develop goes in that
glass and so the bigger your glass the
more of those other qualities you can
develop and so strength maintains a
focus and a foundation for people's
training and it's interesting right now
as as physical training has become more
I'm gonna go old school here for just a
second so if you look at some of the
ancient training systems and I'm drawing
back to the Greeks and the German turned
Brian system and some of these some of
the other old training systems which
primarily came from training military
and and and warriors and things of that
nature
they really had three main components to
them there was a martial component which
was your ability to respond
appropriately to aggression and you
could easily look at that from a martial
arts or military perspective and that
makes very good sense there was a
restorative component because learning
the martial tended to knock you out of
Center and so you needed techniques for
health and recovery
regeneration to be able to go do the
other stuff again and then you had a
pedagogical body of knowledge that
supported the other to fitness has
become our martial art fitness has
become the thing so our pillars of
training have switched to where now our
training our fitness has become this
thing that we do for itself whereas we
used to get fit to go do other things
you know the restorative component in
the ancient systems was meant to just
allow you to go practice the martial
stuff more I'm a very exciting guy I
enjoy hiking so my my training at this
point supports my hiking and and not in
addition to my own training and training
of my students and the teaching that I
do at certs and things that nature
so since Fitness has become this martial
art this thing in and of itself that
that's changed some of our relationships
with with some of these modalities
strength training being one of them
within a competitive environment within
an environment where people are using
Fitness as this display of what they've
accomplished then you start using the
tools of barbells and body weights and
things like that for either higher
repetitions or for conditioning or for
you know these other aspects of physical
development and the strength training
kind of gets can get lost a little bit
that's interesting that Fitness is now
for fitness is sake rather than in
service of another purpose is just an
interesting way to frame it go back to
one of the things that you said at the
beginning about strength being the cup
and everything else filling it would you
be able to explain how you would see
something most people probably wouldn't
link with strength like endurance
capacity perhaps how did those two link
together so one of the easiest examples
that I give is if if it takes you at
this point a thousand motor units to
accomplish some move
and that could be a whatever you want it
to be and we're just talking at very
broad strokes and generalities right
that's we're just gonna say deadlift
everyone knows the deadly let's talk
okay so let's say for the deadlift you
have to recruit at this point
a thousand motor units to accomplish
that movement if I increase your
strength your neural efficiency your
recruitment your your structural ability
your ability to produce tension in that
that efficiency because we we do look at
strength as a skill you know people very
few people look at somebody shooting
free throws and go wow he's a really
good free-throw shooter but he just has
good technique they just say he's a good
free-throw shooter
within strength training there can be
the excuse well he's not that strong he
or she isn't that strong they they just
have good technique like but strength is
a skill and there are we'll talk about
it more later but you know there's
there's people that spend lives 20 30 40
year careers trying to get better at one
or two or three exercises so it's not it
is it is a lifelong pursuit so let's say
due to our training and everything I
take that thousand motor unit
requirement and I drop it to 500 how
would you do that via good strength
training so weak a broader strokes you
become well yes because if neural
efficiency increases if my ability to
recruit and we're gonna sound like I'm
gonna sound manic here for just a second
but let's take a little side journey we
refer to being a strength professional
and when you look at let's use the
benchpress as an example when you look
at a strength professional on the bench
press and they've actually done this
with some EMGs and looking at it this
efficient transfer between muscle groups
during something like the benchpress
when a strength professional gets wedged
in and they begin their benchpress
there's this really smooth transition
from lats to pecs to shoulders to
triceps and it's like being in a formula
racecar right boom boom you don't even
feel the gears change you just go faster
compare that to somebody who's learning
how to drive a stick right you're gonna
get you're gonna get wet whiplash and
and damage your neck because you know
they're you know they're shifting gears
and it's really herky-jerky
and you see that in somebody who's a
novice at the benchpress they'll bring
it down if they don't bounce it then
they'll bring it down and then there's
this big push and there's nothing coming
behind it so it fails and comes back
down or it fails and then the second
muscle group kicks in or you know
however you want to phrase it and so the
the strength professional has learned
how to have these really smooth
transitions throughout a range of motion
displaying producing force against an
object or whatever so yeah that
efficiency leads to the ability to have
greater tension greater efficiency
throughout the movement so I am kind of
staying away from some of the mechanical
properties at the moment and referring
more to the neurological so through good
strength training I make you more
efficient and now I get to the point
that as a result of increased better
recruitment better efficiency
potentially better quality of the tissue
now that thousand motor unit effort is a
500 motor unit effort how many more
times are you going to be able to
produce that 500 motor unit effort
because now you have 500 motor units in
reserve okay so as those initial 500
fatigue you just start tapping into the
500 we now have in reserve and your
endurance has increased by means of
increasing your strength mmm so the word
capacities got up because it's less
effortful to achieve the same movement
yes okay that's interesting so we've
kind of circled around it for a little
bit how how do you contextualize
strength or what are the components of
strength
Wow that's uh that's a broad topic that
point that point so because if we're
sticking with the physical then there is
so let's break that into the
neurological which is the patterning the
efficiency between muscle groups and
really you know having a really high
level of skill in that movement and when
you dive down and you really dig into
something like a deadlift or a bench
press or a squat or clean and jerk or
whatever you want to dig into a one-arm
push-up whatever a case may be that
neurological aspect your ability to
bring your intro abdominal tension your
high tension techniques your efficiency
transitioning through the muscle groups
that neurological aspect is is really
key and that means one of our key
programming principles is we we keep a
continuity of the training process so if
I'm gonna look towards building strength
I'm gonna be doing the same exercises
for a good period of time to allow time
for this learning and efficiency and
gaining of skill if I'm switching
exercises every four weeks I doubt
there's been in a successful Olympic
lifter that has changed exercises at
before weeks they may be modifying their
routine within the context of trying to
optimize the clean-and-jerk in the
snatch but they're gonna work on the
clean and drunk and the snatch and then
highlight areas that need attention so
this continuity of the training process
is going to stick with us so from a
neurological standpoint we're really
focused on the side concept of strength
as a skill and practicing and pursuing
our strength over time via the
continuity from a structural standpoint
now we're talking about the tissue
quality and there's all of these things
that happen within a muscle that produce
movement you can go down to the
the muscle fibers and and look at the
cross bridges and actin and myosin and
myo kinase and and you've got the
calcium going in and out you you know
you have this really complicated
physiological thing and of course the
energy to do that via the ATP and the
mitochondria and all of these things so
there's there's there's these two I
prefer to treat the physiological aspect
as kind of a black box where we do
things and we get a response and I don't
necessarily need to understand all of
the details that's happening in the
black box and actually from a computer
standpoint there's a lot of artificial
intelligence algorithms and things like
that that are basically treated like a
black box they actually don't understand
what's happening inside the AI box but
we get results letting out the other so
the inputs controlled the output is what
you want and to the process in the
middle it doesn't really matter so much
I don't suppose as long as the output is
what you wanted yes I like it so we we
get kind of bogged down into the
physiology because it's fascinating I
mean you talk about the one of the
things that that we work on is this
balance of tension and relaxation and so
it sounds weird for a guy that's all
about strength to be talking about
relaxation but if you're not able to
relax you can never fully bring your
strength to bear and from an athletic
standpoint if I'm walking around half
tight all the time I'm neither efficient
or fast or powerful so I have to be able
to relax
well relaxation actually takes more
energy in the muscle than contraction
because now you have to yeah you have to
pump out the calcium that gave you the
cross bridges and the and the
contraction now you've got to pump that
out in order to create the relaxation
and so there's this there's this balance
to be achieved and your skill at
relaxation can enhance your strength and
your ability to produce power and force
and things of that nature so but that's
complicated like there's a lot going on
in there and I'm I'm a just a good old
knuckle dragger I like I like you know
lift
doing the fun stuff and while I have
gone down some of the rabbit holes of
the the complexity you can still read
the research and see how conflicted we
still are on things like hypertrophy and
other aspects of muscle development so
there's there's a lot going on there so
I just kind of treat that as a black box
and like you said the input the output
and the magic happens in the black box
yeah honestly one of the problems that I
found when I was a young guy and
learning about lifting and stuff some
going back to probably 2007 which is
like bodybuilding.com days like quite
heavily foreign-based and it was so bro
sciency and for every for every article
that you read that said one thing you
could find one that said the opposite
and the same is still true now now for
every person for whom keto works
amazingly there's another person for
whom high carb works amazingly and then
someone will do intermittent fasting and
someone will stick to a more consistent
steady grazing style sort of typical
bodybuilders die and you know it really
is a case of trying to find the
principles I suppose and moving those
forward so I've got a couple of
questions I've got one more question for
you which will come up in a little bit
which I think might be like you trying
to choose your favorite child for now
when we're talking about strength is
progressive overload King yes however
there's always a caveat I know in its it
be it life would be much simpler if we
were able to just give absolutes but
only sifts deal in absolutes so well
we'll stick with the the asterisks and
the caveat
yes progressive overload is the key but
I within this within strong first which
are we call ourselves the school of
strength
we specialize in kettlebell barbell and
body weight not only from a tactical
standpoint but from a programming
standpoint and pavo's recent
work with him plan strong and strong
endurance in particular has with his new
book quicken the dead you can get a
window and some of our new conditioning
and strengthen a conditioning research
and and work that we've been doing the
fourth branch of the school with
strength is programming and in the
development of plan strong when Pavel
took a step back and he looked at the
most successful Olympic lifting
dominance of the Russians and you can
make all the comments you want about the
pharmaceuticals that may have been
involved
but everybody was doing it and the
Russians were still dominant and not
only were they dominant they were
dominant over years Olympic lifting is
not considered a it's a young person's
sport right well they had Russians
setting World Records in their 30s and
late into their 30s and still winning
World Records our world championships
and Olympics and things like that so
when you really look at their
programming yes its progressive over
time but we trend that we tend to treat
that as this linear relationship where
we're always going up when you look at a
very successful program like the
Russians had what you see is that
there's a lot of variability and
actually about 80% of their work
happened around 70% of the 1rm so there
was a tremendous amount of work
happening at a very accessible effort
level which you can recover from and you
can build skill with and you can have
all these great results and then you're
you're doing some work in the top end a
little bit below that but about 75 80
percent of their work happened
in this about 70 percent 1rm sort of
area what's the rep range on that if you
were to go to fail you probably about
six and yes but here's the thing we're
never going to failure so yeah seventy
percent might get you
six to eight and there's tremendous
variability and how people line up on
those rep charts I was always able to
operate actually at a pretty high
percentage of my 1rm but then if you
looked at the charts I should have been
lifting way more oh yeah that's that's
me that's me unfortunately can wrap up
something can rep out eighty eighty
percent of seventy percent for ages but
then just the top end of that curve
flattens off there'll be a lot of people
at home that are the same yeah so what
you're looking for is the progression
over time but you and I just wrote this
article for strong first you have this
waviness in the short term so you're
you're always manipulating that variable
and yeah like I said we're progressive
over time we're not progressive in a
linear standpoint so kind of like the
stock market you know if you look at a
day by day it's doing this if you look
at it over time it does that but if you
just try to do this and be purely linear
you're gonna run into problems why well
if if that was true if I could simply go
to the go down to the bench and add a
pound every day I'd be 365 pounds
heavier in my bench you know year after
year after year which obviously just
doesn't happen
so you fatigue out both from a central
nervous system standpoint because of the
skill driven a neurological driven
aspects of strength and you burnout from
a physiological standpoint because
tissue adaptation tendons and ligaments
are kind of the slowest to adapt we'll
build some big old muscles and the
tendons and ligaments are like dude
we're not ready yet and so you have to
allow time for overall tissue adaptation
and that also responds very well to
having this variation in what you're
doing so that you will allow time for
all these things to come together mmm I
suppose they're cycling through
different movements as you said as well
and sticking to maybe two months with
one particular routine or three months
with one particular routine and then
period izing into something else will
probably allow you to
to achieve that as well so right I'm
gonna Bret I'm gonna ask you the most
difficult question that I can ask you
you're only allowed to do three
exercises for the rest of your life what
are they so yeah you're right it's like
choosing choosing children so I'll give
two different answers but I told you
what I was gonna do
Farah I didn't I didn't dodge the
question okay I just said I was gonna
give you two options for me personally
yes I am a squatter holic I love to
barbell squat because I do a lot of
swings and a lot of kettlebell work I
don't have to do as much work on my
deadlift because I I do a powerful hip
hinge on a consistent basis so I
personally like to squat and I think for
the individual it's finding which are
you do you need to squat do you need to
deadlift because both of those are gonna
give you mileage for a long time if
you're not swinging and working on a
powerful hip hinge then you probably
need to be dead lifting instead of
squatting hmm interesting
if that makes sense yeah yeah there's it
does why why would you put the deadlift
ahead of the squat in isolation it is so
there's a couple and I'm putting in
ahead of that because if I'm swinging
and producing a lot of power in my swing
that I'm already doing all the strength
work I need for my hinge quotation marks
caveat so that's why I put it if you're
not gonna swing you definitely need to
build your hinge and work on your
deadlift and that's not if you're that's
not achievable just with us just for
this well I don't think so I think
there's aspects of the deadlift as far
as the inclusion of the upper body via
the grip and the lats and the way the
deadlift happens that make it a
different animal than the squat the
squat carries with it
more skill requirements you are loading
the spine in a in a unique way so
there's there's different aspects
involved in building that squat
pardon me which I think make the
deadlift a better choice over time for a
broader swath of the population so
that's kind of the from a symmetrical
stand standpoint you need to figure out
whether you need a squad or deadlift yep
we got a push we got to do some sort of
press and military press or bench press
so I told you I was going to give you
two options
military press incorporates the standing
posture you do need to have a very
stable midsection the ability to resist
extension and maintain your position
under that overhead load and so the
military press has I'm gonna say higher
requirements than the bench press mmm Oh
bleep but globally but the bench is a
great way to produce upper body strength
and the way we teach it and really you
bench from your feet and looking at a
good lateral arch not necessarily an AP
arch you set a foundation via the feet
and the lateral arch to really drive
through the upper body so you're gonna
build more upper body mass and strength
via the benchpress you're gonna build
upper body strength via the military
press so picking which one you need
there but you know make your choice I
and we're sticking with strength
training here I do think you need some
sort of pole such as a pull-up
I think the lats are such an important
tie in from upper to lower body and for
everything we want to be doing whether
it's running or dead lifting or
squatting or benching or pressing I
think the last deserve their their
moment kind of the upper body squat as
it was once known mm-hmm I get it well
one thing that I'm interested in is your
inclusion of kettlebells because it's
only been recently for me that I'm
seeing kettlebells really kind of come
into their own guys like yourselves and
on it companies that are really really
pushing the the sort of kettlebell
movements not just as his kettlebells
maybe for me 10 10 years ago would have
been part of the bums and Tom's class
for like my mom to go and do you know I
mean maybe like it
two and a half kilo kettlebell or
something like that and it's kind of
just there to make someone feel like
they're lifting away whereas now there's
much more sophisticated public knowledge
about around the training for that
can you talk Tom through your your
vision and your views on kettlebell
training overall absolutely it's
something that I've been I first got
certified with Pavel in February of o2 I
started teaching with Pavel in April of
oh three so literally for 16 almost 17
years I've been traveling the US and the
world teaching kettlebell training and
certifying others and in the use of the
tool so the kettlebell for me represents
such an excellent entry point to the
world of strength and a bridge towards
the world of conditioning and power work
that make it a really unique and and
really a tool that I think belongs in
everybody's program and everybody in
quotation marks caveat because that's
you know know know one thing for all
people yeah so I think the thick handle
and offset center of mass make it a very
different and alive
tool in your hands where now you're
controlling this rotation or movement of
the center displaced center of mass or
that displaced center of mass is
actually guiding you into better
positions during the movement it so it
requires
a increased level of alignment with
integrity under load and I'm grabbing
that from Grey cook one of my other
mentors and so via the get up in the
press and things like that that take
advantage of this offset center of mass
you have this alignment with integrity
under load which builds this kind of
great postural control which helps set
the foundation for a lot of the strength
and the power work that you want to be
doing and so the kettlebell in my mind
and what I've seen over the the last you
know 17 18 years of using the tool
myself I think it it really fits a need
for people that a dumbbell a barbell
kind of don't provide because that that
weight centers with your grip instead of
being offset an old joke for us as you
can't swing a barbell between your legs
more than once and so the the the
kettlebell allows you to achieve this
really unique loaded eccentric position
which has tremendous carryover for
anything athletic and from a power
standpoint I think that's your ski and
and and others would put it in a power
metric category not plyometric but it
still produces I can produce three three
and a half times bodyweight eccentric
load at the bottom of a 24 kilo
kettlebell swing because it's so dynamic
right exactly and that load of the
eccentric really is unique so I think
kettlebells fulfill check a lot of boxes
and you'll see this if you look at quick
in the dead once you've built a base of
strength power training has a lot to
offer and you have to be strong enough
to be powerful and so we're still not
forgetting that strength is the
foundation but once you have achieved a
base level of strength that power work
really delivers across multiple
spectrums of physical development
whether we're talking about endurance
power or strength with those between
power and strength so
our is how quickly you can apply your
strengths okay
yes strength is how much force you can
produce so it'd be the equivalent of
horsepower versus talk yes I go with
that analogy a very very easily
yeah talky a talkie engine might not be
quite so fast but can pull a very heavy
load high brake horsepower engine can go
very quickly but might not be able to
pull such a heavy thing and then it's in
between the two you have a midpoint okay
so we will have a lot of CrossFitters
and other strength athletes listening
but CrossFit especially we're about to
enter the open which is a period during
which there will inevitably be
kettlebell swings would you be able to
talk us through how you see the optimal
kettlebell swing or what the some of the
coaching cues are that you look for that
you think most people might might mess
up with I think if if I were to give one
piece of advice well we'll make it to
number one is patience true power means
you're patient enough to allow that
power to come to fruition
so it means at the top of my swing and
if it's if it is the games and you are
doing the overhead swing fine you got to
do what's required for the competition
it's waiting for those arms to reach
just pull my camera off oh yeah
you have to wait for those arms to
reconnect for your to your ribs before
you hinge then you have to allow
yourself the time to hinge before you
hit the quick turnaround and now you got
to be patient keeping the arms against
the body as long as you can so you have
this full transfer of energy from the
hips and midsection to the arms in the
bell and so what I see a lot of people
do is they rush that they hinge too
early on the way down they're trying to
come up too quick on the way up and
they're letting the arms disconnect
before they've fully expressed the power
from there
tips so if they would it display
patients at those three stages wait long
enough for the arms to reconnect on the
way down give yourself time to hinge and
then keep the arms against the ribs as
long as possible as you're producing
power through the ground you're gonna
find a much more powerful swing and
better transfer of energy so that more
than anything if people would display
some patience they're gonna be they're
gonna be a lot better off I can
definitely feel in myself when I'm doing
a heavy caliber workout especially when
we are going to the overhead standard
from CrossFit I can tell when that
excitement during a workout takes over
my form I don't know that when that's
happening because my traps get pumped
and it's because I'm going to guess
because I'm upright rowing that that way
up and overhead that pollen pot but as
opposed to allowing myself to swing
through and then yes from there that's
interesting and that's so when when you
look at it from a timing perspective and
it sounds like you know he's saying you
know be patient it's the every reps
gonna take so long and it's not it's
just being patient enough to allow those
things to happen in the proper timing
and sequence you'll actually you know
the rep speed will be not that much
different but it will be that much more
powerful and efficient because now it's
happening in the correct sequence do not
have no effect if to put the barbell let
that put the dump the kettlebell down
half as many breaks perhaps because
you're moving better okay so that's
that's the first one and what's the
what's the second the second cue well I
I went so long into the first one that
I'm okay
sink your breathing oh so interesting
now in there's I'm gonna give you the
kind of there's a we'll call it a
boilerplate answer and then knowing that
there's techniques and strategies to
optimize the breath during an extended
effort
so we have a competition within strong
first called the TSC the tactical
strength challenge and one of the
aspects of that competition is a max
snatches in five minutes so and we have
people that will achieve with a 24 kilo
Bell and some with a 32 kilo Bell will
have people achieving 120 130 140 reps
within 5 minutes it's oh it's it's it's
awful
as soon as I recover from it I'll do it
again yeah but so you know the sniffing
to have good intra-abdominal pressure
and and and bracing during the hinge and
then having the forced exhale match with
when the hips finish that syncs your
power so that your power is efficient
over a number of reps ok so what happens
is during a sustained effort you will
reach a time point where the need for
oxygen becomes great and so that
breathing pace needs to change one of
the easiest ways to change with that
especially within a 5 minute effort is
the double inhale so during the hinge
instead of having a single inhale you
have a double inhale and so you're
actually kind of filling the tank and
topping it off and then having the
exhale synced with the hips and then
there's ways to have multiple breathing
cycles within every rep and so there's
double breathing right nitty-gritty here
that I guess this is how you get exactly
130 cowbells not using five minutes up
right and that's why I prefer the
boilerplate answer yep because getting
into the double breathing gets a little
more complex yeah so what we're talking
about is that you're going to breathe
out as your arms are releasing contact
with the body on the way up is that
correct yeah I would I would sink it
more with the finish of the hips okay
rather than thinking about the arms but
you are not releasing the arms from
ribs until the hips finish so that yes
understood okay and then as you're
coming back down you're taking the
breath in just before you begin to hinge
yes so when you hit the bottom you've
got that bubble of intra-abdominal
pressure that gives you something to
then produce force against on the way up
yes there's definitely been times I can
think of I'm sure that the listeners
will be able to sympathize as well when
you are breathing too much and you just
get out of time and you're fully exhaled
at the bottom as you're swinging in
kettlebell through your legs and it
feels like someone's come up behind you
and kicked you in the middle of the ass
and you're like yeah nearly fall forward
into the into the workout which is nice
not great again as you say a lot of the
people that will be listening may be
doing these under fatigue you know if
you're a CrossFit athlete and you've got
this in amongst a bunch of rowing and
potentially pull-ups or something else
and you grips going and everything else
like that you do need to be you do need
to be delicate with that so I suppose
trying to adhere to that as closely as
possible is not gonna be a bad idea
definitely and and that would lead into
it potentially another podcast on the
concept of the difference between your
training and your testing and the fact
that your your training does not always
have to look like you're testing and you
build capacity and minimize fatigue
rather than always trying because
conditioning and I know we're getting
away from the strength message but the
conditioning is kind of falling into the
primary camp that conditioning is
falling into is building tolerance
basically this is gonna suck so we're
gonna do it and over time it will suck
less because you are have better
tolerance to this there is another way
and in building capacity your ability to
handle the energy production and the
byproducts and the the the efficiency of
the of the organism versus the tolerance
of the organism and so I've went and
again you look at quick in the dead and
pop
new stuff you'll see a lot on this you
can build a lot of capacity and have hmm
have better health kind of lower injury
better performance and test better but
if you're always testing yourself and
you're burning that candle hard it's
like having a NAS it's like having a
nitric oxide on your car well if you're
using that to go pick up a loaf of bread
you're gonna burn out your car you want
to save that for that one moment where
you need that extra boost is that where
the 70% also window appears to be
optimal is that one of the reasons why
that will be in there as well it is
interesting because again I'm around a
lot of CrossFitters I'm just around a
lot of athletes who like to go hard as
well whatever that particular given
field there is a subgroup that training
our gym who are just sadists and they
enjoy they enjoy getting into that one
90 BPM Heart range like that's that's
what they live for and I you know is it
is very unique in the fitness world
based on what I know having spoken to
guys like dr. McGill Brian Carroll as
well these sorts of guys who talk about
embedding the movement engrams in as
perfect a way as possible especially if
we're talking about you know big lifts
that need to be perfect and doing those
under fatigue appears to be a very very
dangerous way to Train yes I I would I
would agree with that and I and I think
that there's one reason we prefer
something like the kettlebell swing
kettlebell snatch as our display of
maintaining our skill over time under
fatigue because there's there's
different ways to look at this and as
we're building pardon me as we're
building these patterns I have to load
you to find out if that pattern is going
to hold up under the load and then I
need to
especially if I'm training an athlete or
somebody I'm gonna have to push you into
some fatigue to see if that pattern is
gonna hold up under the fatigue and it's
my job as a coach to know when to pull
back because you're not handling the the
fatigue in the form or the load in the
form and so that's where my skill comes
in to say no that's enough for today
or yes you can push go a little further
so definitely yeah can you suggest any
heuristics or rules that people who
don't have a coach that's on hand can
use so it's rigged I'm gonna couch this
in a couple of different ways I would
say that rest is the single most abused
training variable hmm we we don't rest
enough and I remember years ago when the
high intensity interval training really
became popular and was basically a
response to this idea that nobody had
time to Train and so here comes this
high intensity interval sort of
protocols and Tabata which nobody's ever
done Tabata outside of the original
Tabata research it's it's a miserable
thing to it to even think about much
less endure and and just cause you're
doing you know burpees for 20 seconds on
10 seconds off you're not doing Tabata
it was a completely different thing but
anyway yep you know here comes this
message that you have this high
intensity with short rest for a
compressed period of time and you
accomplish all of these great things
that's yes you will for a little while
and then the wheels will fall off why
because it's like a crash diet
you just can't maintain it it's you know
if you're if we're doing the cabbage
soup diet you know we're gonna lose a
lot of weight and accomplish some great
short-term results and then we're not
going to because nutritional
deficiencies and problems will set in
when you burn the candle to both ends
and in the middle and you're burning the
NAS every time you go into the session
the car eventually falls apart
you just can't handle that level of
stress over that period of time you
exceed the ability of the organism to
compensate and recover from that stress
and again we're back into the capacity
versus tolerance discussion and I would
rather build capacity and have this
health aspect to my training I'm an
ancient forty eight years old and I can
tell you that I enjoy the health aspect
of my training from a strength
standpoint I was the eleventh guy in the
world to bend the red nail I've
accomplished a good number of grip
strength feats some decent not great
powerlifting numbers raw and so I built
my strength and I've worked on that end
of things I've snatched a kettlebell a
bunch of times and worked on the
conditioning end of things but the only
place health comes before or Fitness
comes before health is in the dictionary
your your training should be driving you
towards a better stand point as far as
your health is concerned and we may
sacrifice that from time to time in
order to accomplish a performance goal
certainly if your goal I was working
with a guy at a workshop and his goal
was to bench 500 and he was doing
whatever it took and you can read into
that whatever you want to he was doing
whatever it took to get to 500 and I
gave him a couple of mobility techniques
and things to work on because he was
really suffering with his shoulders and
but he was going to do whatever it took
to accomplish that goal as long as he's
willing to change goals once he's
accomplished that and regained the
health of his shoulders and body and
things of that nature
fine like we make these decisions from
time to time if you're gonna run a
marathon get get ready to spend a lot of
money on treatment and surviving the
training in the marathon and then
hopefully you get healthy you know on
the back end of that so we make those
decisions as long as those are conscious
decisions and things we've we've
factored in it's the only thing we know
how to do is burn ourselves to a frazzle
beef
forced to take time off either due to
illness or injury and then burn
ourselves to a frazzle again I think
there's a better way
reminds me of Eddie Hall hearing him
talking about the way that his body was
and how he felt around about the time
when he won World's Strongest Man and he
was talking about the fact that his
marriage was falling apart he's barely
seeing his kids and he was so heavy that
he could I think he's like 190 kilos and
he's at five nine or something or like
five ten or something like that some
inordinate sizes wide as he was tall and
and he was talking about all of these
different things but as you say he said
I wanted to be the world's strongest man
I was prepared to do whatever it took to
do that but one thing I've got a massive
amount of respect for Eddie for is
seeing the transformation that he's
undergone after he completed that goal
and he did complete that goal he got
where he wanted to and he has taken a
complete step back from the professional
side of that sport I was doing other
stuff he's doing a a lot more varied
fitness challenges I think he's like
swimming and stuff at the moment it's a
sight to see him in a pool but yeah you
know you're right people are prepared to
make sacrifices for things that they
deemed to be valuable to them given
their values in life they think try this
will make me feel satisfied and give me
a sense of accomplishment if I X run
this marathon deadlift 600 pounds
benchpress 500 pounds whatever it might
be there is a there is a treadmill that
people can get on where they don't
realize that if there isn't a goal at
the end of that if it's just fitness for
Fitness's sake if there's no end point
if there's no periodization that's when
you get people that do get severe burn
out or they end up with a very serious
injury
so yeah you mentioned about one of the
ways that the people can self judge when
they're pushing themselves too hard and
when they potentially need to move back
towards capacity so so with with let's
go within a session because I think
that's important if your rep speed is
slowing down if your so your tempo
changes and I I have a very easy metric
on that if I'm doing swings and I know
ten swings takes me roughly 17 to 18
seconds if that 10 swing starts taking
me 20 21 seconds I'm slowing down I am
beating the proverbial dead horse it is
time for me to stop or increase my rest
periods so seeing tempo change exceeding
about an 8 out of 10 and Rp unable to
catch your breath you know you're not
able to recover before the next set I've
been a slave to the clock for years and
have over the last couple of years
worked very hard to free myself from the
clock and allowing myself better
recovery and not surprisingly seeing
better results in my training so those
are just some some easy kind of stop
signs that we talked about with them
strong first that you know within a
session within a set within a session
within a training session we look for
those things
the I think it's very interesting I was
asked one time on a podcast what my
favorite recovery strategy was and I
think it's interesting that we have an
entire cottage industry of recovery
strategies that have grown up around
this idea of how do I recover from the
training that I'm doing well my answer
was proper programming if I have myself
programmed appropriately if I am taking
into account the organism and my overall
stress nutrition sleep ability to handle
work
and the environment my programming and
things of that nature if I've got those
two things taken care of and I have done
well with this environmental
consideration of the program then I
should be recovering from my training I
shouldn't be always trying to figure out
how I'm going to recover probably one of
the easiest answers to people who are
always trying to figure out how to
recover from the training is do less
yeah you're right if you're if you're
constantly having to flap your wings so
hard to stay afloat
it's probably just time that you need to
reassess the program overall decide that
you're gonna just take a little bit more
rest time whatever it might be and
that's I think because we are exposed to
the work rate of everybody else online
with social media and being able to now
see a window into the lives of
professional athletes or
semi-professional athletes or just you
know your normal gym athlete who happens
to have a ridiculous work capacity
because you're able to see them you use
the canary in the coalmine for how hard
are you working is how hard the day
working and that can lead to people
setting themselves a standard which is
unreachable given their physiology there
are some people whose ability to recover
they can recover fine from a really hard
workout on seven hours sleep there's
some people who require you know ten and
I guess that's a decision you need to
make yourself it is and if you're if
you're mindful of your recovery and your
health and you know things of that
nature and and you know if you're
constantly dealing with a quotation
marks' injury you have a pain problem or
thing that you're constantly having to
manage you're probably pushing too hard
if you're you know if illness is a
repeated thing for you you're probably
pushing too hard and you have to take in
overall life stress into consideration
if you're sleeping four hours a night
working two jobs and you're having a lot
of interpersonal stress yeah you're not
going to be pushing very hard on your
training because your your recovery
ability is already taxed by this
lifestyle stress
or if your simple your diet simply
doesn't support your training then
expect to suffer and have trouble
recovery this is hype a mentality though
isn't it that there are some people for
whom you tell them to do a and they will
do ten well why did you do ten I told
you easy wait well I just thought mores
better and then if I roll that out if
you scale that across someone's entire
life yeah you end up with that so final
question I wanted to ask and I spoke to
Brian Carroll about this and I thought
it was really interesting I know the dr.
McGill agrees with this I'd be
interested to hear your thoughts for
strength athletes power lifter
weightlifter Brian and Stewart are of
the opinion that training the movement
once per week is optimal for them to
cycle for most athletes what's your
stance on that depends on the athlete
for the broadest cross-section of
athletes that you know what would you
say so it's almost impossible because
the where that athlete is on the
spectrum where that individual is on the
spectrum matters if you're reaching a
true physiological peak where you know
your strength is really based on your
structure and anatomy and ability to
recover and everything is actually
reaching a physiological peak and you're
able to push yourself to that limit then
yes you can train less frequently but if
you look at the Russian powerlifting
team they bench seven days a week no way
yeah they bench like every day caught us
it's because there and multiple
sometimes multiple sessions in a day
it's because their training is very wavy
and very wavy stuff they did bench days
every day of the week for the Russians
what's going on if you look at shake oh
and and the the Russian powerlifting
team they they do a lot of work and so
there's there's kind of this classic
American powerlifting
sort of mindset at Kohn Marty Gallagher
Karofsky a lot of classic American power
lifting that is very linear it is
working each main lift once a week
there's the Russian method which has
multiple sessions per week both have had
their success stories yeah it's figuring
out which one you tolerate and where you
are on that spectrum that would dictate
those decisions if I'm working with a
younger in their progression if I'm
working with a younger physiological age
athlete and that can happen at any age
I could be working with a 50 year old
who's just getting into strength
training and they're at a very young
physiological age that individual I
might want to deadlift five days a week
because I'm building that pattern and
they're still grooving it practicing it
once a week is not going to get them to
a skill level where they can actually
build an appreciable level of strength
but yet if that's the 30 year old
athlete who really has been pushing hard
and is nearing a physiological peak yeah
I might be dead lifting them once a week
I love how I love how Russian the
Russian approach is like the most we we
do bench today like what do you want to
get better at I want to get better at
bench guess what we're gonna be doing
we're gonna be mentioned so yeah it is
it is a very utilitarian minimalist sort
of mindset and we we get into muscle
confusion and you know all of these
different things and and the pursuit of
building strength actually means
dedicating yourself to a very narrow
window of things that you're going to be
doing now you look at something like
Westside where Lois Simmons not only had
and there's west sides very interesting
but they were trying to optimize three
lifts but Louis has like 200 assistants
exercises for the bench because he would
spot a weak spot in your bench
and had a drill to address that weak
spot so it wasn't variety for varieties
sake
it was variety meant to progress you in
that main goal but the goal never
changed the continuity of the training
process was always there and that you
know strength training means dedicating
yourself towards a goal of building
strength and doing that over time and
having this continuity of training
process that leads to success isn't it
interesting that there's so many
different paths to achieving the same
goal that you have Russians competing
with Americans stepping on to the same
platform within minutes of each other
but some training methodologies that
couldn't look more different in some
ways or the assaulter guys from West
Side in the equipt leagues who are going
up against other people who may never do
anything other than big compound lifts
they might that they're accessory work
might be pull-ups and that's it or you
know it's so I find it fascinating that
there are all of these different routes
and it comes back to what we said at the
very beginning right well it's like you
can find an proof for effectiveness of
proof or ineffectiveness for pretty much
everything so at the end of the day this
is a nice way to round it off I suppose
does the training methodology that you
choose come down to personal preference
for the one that you can adhere to the
the most and that feels the best for you
and how are you supposed to select I
have this myriad of training
opportunities in front of me how do I
choose so I think to get started let's
start there to get started the basics
work three to five sets of three to five
reps three to five days a week just to
keep it as simple as possible with with
some variation in what you're doing that
will build strength and for the beginner
I don't want to say almost any program
will work but almost any program work
you know for the beginner
it's when you have built a base of
strength and you're trying to specialize
and aim yourself in a particular
direction
then the next training protocol carries
more weight strength training joke
carries more weight in how you're gonna
succeed in that
keeping in mind health and progress you
know as long as you're being mindful of
those then you got to know when to stop
a routine and make a change you don't
want to and I know the the I've seen it
referred to as struggle porn where
there's this message out there that you
got a grind and you're gonna grind and
you're gonna grind and you put all these
hours in and you grind and believe me I
I put in the hours and and that's not a
problem for me but you can grind too far
and too deeply and cause yourself
problems you you don't want to quit
before the process comes to fruition but
you got to know when the process isn't
going to come to fruition and you got to
make a change so kind of a dichotomy
there to work with so figuring out
whether you're a high volume or low
volume athlete I think is one of the
most important distinctions from a
strength training standpoint and I have
friends of mine that can handle a very
high number of lifts per month I am NOT
that person I am NOT a high volume
trainee if I do a high volume routine it
needs to be six weeks to eight weeks and
yeah small windows and then get away
from it because the the siren song of
volume becomes a little too strong I
mean if you overload yourself exactly
Brett thank you so much for today it's
been great if the listeners want to find
out some more info what the books been
that we've cited today and where else
can they add so if you go to strong
first calm you'll find everything there
from the community forum are articles
and and things of that nature a lot of
information available there
the book is quicken the dead the quicken
the dead and has some tremendous
information and it
and you'll you'll see our barbell
kettlebell and bodyweight sort of
modalities represented on the website
and in on the form so kind of a one-stop
shop
a lot of information to be gained there
I love it thank you so much for your
time hoping that would make some people
a little bit stronger any questions that
you have feel free to throw them in the
YouTube comments below and I'll try and
hassle Brett if there's if there's
anything specific that I can't answer
myself but for now Brett thank you very
much
beautiful thank you sir it was great to
have the opportunity
[Music]
you